uno de los activistas por los derechos
sociales más destacados del mundo y el
hombre que está detrás del sueño
sudafricano de una nación arcoiris
desmon tutú podría despertar a grandes
multitudes mientras predicaba su mensaje
de no violencia lideró la lucha contra
el apartheid en sudáfrica con sus
discursos y siguió manifestándose por la
liberación de los presos políticos
durante años después de que se ganara
esa batalla cuando el líder del
movimiento de conciencia negra steve
biko fue asesinado por la policía en
1977 desmon tutú pronunció el sermón
fúnebre huelin
chang el riesgo bastante cuando dije lo
de todos seremos libres un día negros y
blancos y añadí repitan después de mí y
lo hicieron en lo más profundo de
nuestras mentes los sudafricanos sabemos
que nuestro destino es estar juntos game
window willow tu queda
este era su sueño de una nación arcoiris
un concepto que le hizo famoso diez años
después cuando el régimen del apartheid
había caído el presidente nelson mandela
lo puso al frente de la comisión de la
verdad y la reconciliación
pasó más de dos años escuchando
historias de encarcelamiento y tortura
tras superar un cáncer de próstata tutu
decidió salir de las fronteras de
sudáfrica para unirse a la lucha por la
justicia mundial resultó ser una ilusión
desde los campos de refugiados de sudán
del sur hasta la crisis postelectoral en
costa de márfil a lo largo de todos sus
viajes siguió siendo una activista por
la paz franco y a veces polémico atacó a
israel por el trato que da a los
palestinos calificándolo de apartheid
moderno pero su principal objetivo fue
el presidente sudafricano jacob zuma al
que acusó de corrupción en 2013 tutu
anunció que dejaría de votar al cn a el
partido gobernante que derribó el
apartheid palabras que llegarían a tener
sus consecuencias en diciembre de ese
año en el psuv mandela murió a los 95
años mientras los líderes mundiales se
reunían para presentar sus últimos
respetos desmon tutú sólo tuvo dos
minutos para rendir homenaje a su viejo
amigo
podemos entonces devolverle la sonrisa a
dios banco active a pesar de las
terribles historias de quienes se
cruzaron en su camino las sonrisas las
risas y los bailes de desmon tutú
demostraron que tenía una fe que podía
poner fin a la injusticia
[Aplausos]